the election of 2016
felt different political conversations
with our family and friends uncovered a
level of polarization that many of us
had not previously experienced people
who we always thought were reasonable
and intelligent seemed like strangers we
said to ourselves how could you think
that I thought you were smart
Kaitlyn and I met in the summer of 2011
and we bonded around being working moms
and trying to keep our very energetic
boys busy and we soon found out we had
almost everything in common from our
love of Colorado to our love of sushi
there wasn't much we didn't agree on we
also discovered that we share a deep
love of this country and feel a
responsibility to be politically active
but no one's perfect
and I soon found out too disappointing
things about Kaitlyn first she hates
camping
I think camping is the worst so there
would not be any joint camping trips in
our future the second thing is that
she's politically active all right as a
conservative I may hate camping but I
love politics I listen to conservative
talk radio just about every day and I
volunteered for a few different
conservative political campaigns and I'd
say I'm a little to the left like all
the way to the left I've always been
interested in politics I was a political
science major and I worked as a
community organizer and on a
congressional campaign so as Lauren and
I were getting to know each other it was
right in the middle of that 2012
presidential campaign and most of our
early political conversations were
really just based in jokes and pranks so
as an example I would change Lauren's
computer screensaver to a picture of
Mitt Romney or she would put an Obama
campaign magnet on the back of my car
car not minivan but over time those
conversations grew more serious and
really became a core of our friendship
and somewhere along the line we decided
we didn't want to have any topic be
off-limits for discussion even if those
topics push this way outside of our
friends
comfort zone and sir most of us
political conversations are a zero-sum
game there's a winner and there's a
loser we go for the attack we spot a
weakness in someone's argument and
here's the important part we tend to
take every comment or opinion that's
expressed as a personal affront to our
own values and beliefs but what if we
change the way we think about these
conversations what if in these heated
moments we chose dialogue over a debate
when we engage in dialogue we flip the
script we replace our ego and our desire
to win with curiosity empathy and a
desire to learn instead of coming from a
place of judgment we're genuinely
interested in the other person's
experiences their values and their
concerns you make it sound so simple
Florin but getting to that place of true
dialog is hard especially when we're
talking about politics it is so easy to
get emotionally fired up about issues
that were passionate about and we can
let our ego get in the way of truly
hearing the other person's perspective
and in this crazy political climate
we're in right now unfortunately we're
seeing an extreme result of those heated
political conversations to the point
where people are willing to walk away
from their relationships in fact
rasmussen released a poll earlier this
year that said 40% of people reported
that the 2016 election negatively
impacted a personal relationship and the
Journal of cognitive neuroscience tells
us that people tend to feel their way to
their beliefs rather than using
reasoning and that when reason and
emotion collide it's emotion that
invariably wins so no wonder it's hard
to talk about these issues and look
we're just two regular friends who
happen to think very differently about
politics and the role the government
should play in our lives and I know we
were all taught not to talk about
politics because it's not polite but we
need to be able to talk about it because
it's important to us and it's a part of
who we are we have chosen to avoid
political debate and instead engage in
dialogues in order to maintain what we
fondly call our bipartisan friendship
and this election and all of the
craziness that has followed has given us
several opportunities to practice this
skill let's start with January in the
women's March at this point you can
probably guess which one of us
participated oh the women's March I was
annoyed and irritated that entire day
really because of two things number one
the name women's March as a conservative
woman the marches platform of issues
didn't represent me and that's okay but
hearing it talked about as this
demonstration of sisterhood and
solidarity for all women didn't ring
true for me the other piece was the
timing of the event the fact that it was
the day after the presidential
inauguration it felt like we weren't
even giving the new administration to
actually do anything good or bad before
people felt the need to demonstrate
against it and under normal
circumstances I would agree with Caitlyn
I think an administration does deserve
the benefit of the doubt but in this
case I was marching to show my concern
that a man was such a poor track record
with women and other groups had been
elected as president I had to be part of
the collective voice that wanted to send
a clear message to the new president
that we did not accept or condone his
behavior or rhetoric during the election
so I'm already feeling kind of
aggravated and then I see this Facebook
some lorem pop-up in my social media
seed seeing Lauren Suns at the March and
holding signs took it to a new level for
me and not in a good way because I know
these boys
I love these boys and I just didn't feel
like they were old enough to understand
what the March stood for I didn't
understand why Lauren would choose to
have them participate in that way and I
assumed it wasn't a choice that the boys
made for themselves but I also know
Lauren you're an incredible mom who
would never exploit your boys in any way
so I had to stop and check myself I had
a decision to make I could take the easy
way out and just choose not to say
anything anything to her and instead
just kind of simmer in my frustration or
I could ask her to learn more about her
motivations and I shared with Kaitlin
that we actually started talking about
the March weeks before we participated
and my boys were curious as to why the
event was being or
organized in this led to some very
interesting family conversations we
talked about how in this country we have
the right and the privilege to
demonstrate against something we don't
agree with and my husband shared with
them why he thought it was so important
that men joined the women's March but
the most significant reason we marched
as a family is that it was a way for us
to honor my parents legacy they spent
their careers working to defend the
rights of some of our most vulnerable
citizens and they passed these values
down to me and my brother and we want to
do the same with our sons after talking
to Lauren I really understood not only
why she felt it was so important to
March but why she had her boys with her
and frankly my assumptions were wrong it
was the boys who wanted to march after
they talked about the issues as a family
but what's most important about this
example is to think about the
alternative had Lauren and I not talked
about it I would have been annoyed with
her and it could have resulted in an
undercurrent of disrespect in our
friendship but by asking Lauren
questions it allowed us to use dialogue
to get to a place of true understanding
now to be clear our conversation didn't
really change my mind about how I felt
about the March but it absolutely
changed my thinking around why she
brought her boys with her and for both
of us that dialogue allowed us to
understand each other's perspective
about the women's March even though we
disagreed the second topic that
challenged our ability to engage in
dialogue was around my need to
understand how Kaitlyn could vote for
Trump
kaitlin is a successful professional
woman who is deeply caring and
compassionate and the Kaitlin I know
would never excuse any man from talking
about women the way that Trump did
during the campaign it was hard for me
to reconcile these two things in my mind
how could you overlook the things that
were said so I'm guessing I may not be
the only one here that thought we didn't
have the best choices for the
presidential election last year the
Republican candidate who I did support
didn't make it out of the primary so
when it came time to vote I had a
decision to make and you're right there
were some terrible things that came out
during the Trump campaign so much so
that I almost decided to just abstain
rather than voting for president
something I had never even considered
doing before but ultimately I did vote
for Donald Trump and for me it was
really a vote for party over person
especially recognizing how important
that presidential pick is on influencing
our judicial branch but I shared with
Lauren it was a decision I really
wrestled with and not one that I made
lightly and so after our conversation I
was struck by a few things first I had
fallen victim to my own confirmation
bias because of my strong feelings about
Trump
I had given all Trump voters the same
attributes and none of them forgiving
but knowing Caitlyn I started to ask
questions what were Trump voters really
concerned about under all the divisive
language what was really going on what
could we learn about ourselves in our
country from this unlikely event I also
learned that we shared a deep
disappointment in the selection and that
we have growing concerns about our
two-party political system but the most
important thing about this conversation
is that it happened at all
without an open and honest dialogue
between the two of us this election
would have been the elephant in the room
for the next four years pun intended
[Laughter]
so look we know it takes work to get
past the difficult frustrating and
sometimes emotional parts of having
discussions about issues like the
women's March or why your friend may
have voted for a candidate that you
can't stand but we need to have these
conversations our ability to move past
political debate into true dialogue is a
critical skill we should all be focused
on right now especially with the people
that we care about the most and it's not
just as adults that we need to bottle
this behavior we it's critical that we
do it for our children as well my sons
were inundated with this election we
were listening to the news in the
morning and they were having
conversations with their friends at
school I was concerned that they were
picking up so much polarizing
misinformation and they were growing
really fearful of a trump presidency
then one day I was taking after the
election I was taking my son's to school
and my younger son completely out of the
blue said mom we don't know anybody who
voted for Trump right
and I pause I took a deep breath yes we
do the plot Romani's and his response
was so great he kind of got this
confused look on his face and he said
but we love them and I answered yes we
do
and then he said why would they vote for
him and I remember stopping and thinking
that it was really important how I
answered this question somehow I had to
honor our own family values and show
respect for our friends so I finally
said they think that's the right
direction for this country and of course
before I had even gotten the whole
sentence out of my mouth he had moved on
to the soccer game who's gonna play at
recess so a life with boys so what
Lauren and I have discovered through our
bipartisan friendship is the possibility
that lives in dialog we have chosen to
be genuinely curious about each other's
ideas and perspectives and to be willing
to listen to one another even when we
disagree and by putting aside our ego
and our preconceived ideas we've opened
ourselves up to limitless learning and
perhaps most importantly for our
relationship we have made the commitment
to each other that our friendship is way
more important than either of us being
right or winning a conversation about
politics so today we're asking you to
have a conversation talk to someone
outside of your political party who
might challenge your thinking make an
effort to engage with someone with whom
you might typically avoid a political
conversation but remember the goal isn't
to win the goal is to listen and to
understand and to be open to learning
something new so let's go back to
election night as the polls were closing
and it became clear that Trump was going
to be our new president I was devastated
I was sad I was confused and I'll be
honest I was angry and then just before
midnight I received this text message
from Caitlin
and we're there so easily could have
been weeks or months of awkwardness and
unspoken hostility there was this an
offering of empathy rooted in friendship
and I knew in that moment that we would
make it through this so we must find a
way to engage in meaningful
conversations that are going to move us
forward as a nation and we can no longer
wait for our elected officials to
elevate our national discourse the
challenges ahead are going to require
all of us to participate in a deeper and
more meaningful way
and it starts with each one of us
building connection through dialogue in
our relationships our communities and as
a country thank you
[Applause]